showing me your place it's all about the
right spices so this is your kitchen
your workshop yes sucharita Ishwara is
in bangalore visiting entrepreneur
Gayatri Rao she makes spice mixes she
wants to make sure the packaging is
appealing and she hopes sucharita can
help her marketer products nationwide
Gayatri is a start-up entrepreneur and
so that's one group that comes to us and
we are very excited because it's a new
idea they're at the starting stage so we
can be with them right from the
beginning of the journey daya trees
website has recently gone online now
she's working on a business plan because
she needs a bank loan to increase
production but she's also dealing with a
different challenge I've had experiences
where I've had to deal with vendors or
things to be done when we were putting
up the unit they wouldn't respond to my
calls but they would immediately respond
if my dad made a call or my brother made
a call okay sucharita a schwa run der
stands this problem as a young woman she
wanted to have a career when her
marriage failed 16 years ago she felt
stranded as a single mother she had to
take care of her finances and raise her
two daughters by herself all that made
me realize that it's very very important
for girls to be brought up in a way
where they are totally independent and
they think independently and they are
not influenced by the cultural
conditioning which exists in our world
that women are primarily to be seen as
homemakers and mothers game if you say
so elated when she created her own
company with a circle of like-minded
entrepreneurs many of her friends were
skeptical for her daughter Tara though
it was a logical step honestly I think
the one thing that she continues to keep
drilling into me she's like don't think
small think big just you know imagine
whatever you want and follow your heart
I think that's the one thing that she
keeps us to keep reminding me once in a
while as well all this violence against
women attacks and molestation of women
that you see is often against girls who
are working who have chosen to lead an
independent life and the boys are still
being brought up to think that women are
there as subservient to them about them
and it's okay to attack them or they
need to be taught a lesson so that they
start going back to their traditional
roles so we are seeing a lot more
conflict in our society today because of
that how is it white sucharita ash
warren her network aim to help women
achieve their business goals at meetings
like this they share their experiences
the young entrepreneurs present their
products and have to answer some tough
questions before they receive any
support for the next stage and you have
a space at home access to finance is a
big challenge the second one is access
to markets so they do start out and then
as they think of growing bigger they are
thinking okay where do I actually now
start marketing who might be additional
customers or market segments that I can
address how do I reach them so that's
another big area the third one is the
challenge in using technology the
network also encourages women it hosts
frequent gatherings this evening there
at a popular bar in Bangalore connecting
to the right resources getting
information about what the government is
doing for women entrepreneurs
and you know what is the right way
forward so that kind of support is the
first thing that I get from cwe and
second is you know getting to know how
other women entrepreneurs are doing it
this is a great platform to do shared
learning we are a public relations firm
so we are specifically looking for
companies who are interested in media
visibility for your startup or for your
form so through a meet like this we met
quite a few interesting startup who have
great media potential positions are held
by men so when you go and tell them that
you know I would like to do business
with you it's like a setback that you
are a woman would you be able to
understand what we are doing stanky
program that's something many of these
educated independent minded women don't
like to hear for sucharita ishwara it's
clear that women entrepreneurs are
making the world a better place I think
they really stay in a business for the
long run so they create sustainable
businesses when they seriously get into
starting and running a business they're
not thinking of exiting or selling it in
three years five years and making a big
pile of money and going out there
looking to grow it consistently
year-on-year so that's rubaba sucharita
ish Juarez that if she and her network
succeed in improving the situation of
even one young female entrepreneur it
will all have been worth while
[Music]